all right so now come back to your book
and let's think about how we can
visualize what's happening i want to
draw what's going on here
okay so i'm going to draw this section
of the complex plane so
you'll need your pen for this right and
i want to try
and come up with a more succinct way of
visualizing and understanding what's
going on here
okay so here's my complex plane
um i've chosen spots one two
three one and three are my reference
points
as it were because i get that from here
these are my points of comparison
right and then at least i've found one
example of a point where it satisfies
this so let's draw it sort of roughly
there maybe yours is somewhere else you
can draw it anywhere you like it's
really quite fine
i'm going to put mine roughly
roughly there i want to call that point
pape that i found here
okay now what have i got
on this diagram where are these
important angles that i'm trying to
understand right
well because this is three this
obtuse angle here is arg
of z minus three right does that make
sense
it's the argument 2z from
three okay and then if you have a look
at this
angle tucked in here what's that angle
it's argov z minus one fantastic so
let's go ahead and label that
so far so good now on this diagram
there's another angle which it might not
jump out at you is important but it's
going to get us to the connection to
today's starter question it's this angle
right in here
theta it's at the top where where p is
okay now
i want to know what that angle is equal
to for this magical point that i seem to
have found or maybe the magical point
you've found
right so i can reason i think
i think i'll be able to fit it in just
over here if i make it's a little bit
wider
and i'd like you to reason with me right
if you have a look at these two
angles here right do you see they're
inside the triangle
and they are opposite to this larger
angle on the outside right
interior exterior this is a this is a
triangle geometry property we learned
way back in year 78 right
i can say that the two
interior angles which in this case are r
z minus one and theta if you add them up
you should get r z minus three
right and um we should jot down i'm
gonna have to write that off
we should jot down our reason for that
right the exterior angle
of a triangle the exterior angle
equals
how would we word this the um the sum
you have to add up these two things
right very good thank you smith this
you're on here on fire today
um the sum of the opposite interior
angles i think is perfect perfect
the opposite
interior angles okay now taking this
statement that connects these two
arguments and this theta let me write
that a bit neater my writing
surroundings today
what i can do is i can subtract r of z
minus one i'm just going to underline it
for you so you can see what i'm doing
i can subtract this from both sides and
i get something useful
have you noticed it if i subtract it
from both sides i get
arg of z minus 3 over here is already on
the right hand side
and then i subtract arg of z minus
1. is that okay i just subtracted from
both sides
have a look at this right hand side you
know what this right hand side is equal
to
don't you what's it equal to from the
question
it's pi on two so this angle on the
inside
the angle up at the top of the triangle
is pi on two
and this tells us something really
really critically important and it comes
back to the starter question that we did
right you know how you guys found alpha
plus beta
which i had originally placed here well
alphabetically is also here that's how
we solve the question
right now if that's pi on two
what you've got here is a right angle
and this is actually so important that
it gets its own kind of statement this
is a circle geometry
property that the angle in a semi-circle
can see this is the diameter so this is
a semi-circle at the top
the angle in a semi-circle is a right
angle it's so important we should jot it
down together right
the angle in a semicircle
[Applause]
is a right angle
now what this means is if we have a
think about
i'll just get rid of my protractors now
if we have a think about
uh this which i think you already have
right you've got two measurements there
an angle on the
right an angle on the left and then
underneath that you've got the
difference between them do you have that
did i
set that up right on your screen yes
okay so you can see
you can move this around and sometimes
you get
uh let's find a spot let's find a spot
over
there whoops there we go can you see on
the left hand side i found another point
where the difference is between the
angles and 90 degrees and you can find
an infinite number of these right
if you can do it well you should be able
to find some
uh i need to go further where am i going
there we go that's better
there's another one on the other side
right now what shapes
are the tr these um these different
points plotting out well it's
what we just made this statement about
right that angle has to be
pi on two radians which means
see if i did it right it's all of these
points sorry you don't have this in
yours because that would have been
cheating
it's all the points that sit on this
semi-circle this arc that you can see
and now you can try and sort of like
trace it out right can you see how close
i stay my finger's just stubby so i
can't do it very accurately but
there we go that's a bit better so long
as i stay on the semicircle i'm getting
this difference
of 90 degrees of pi on 2 radians does
that make sense
so you've waited long enough the heading
you can make on this is
semi-circles
and what we are saying is if you think
back to last week
when we get these like pairs of points
right the locus that you get is
sometimes
say um the interval between the two
points but then we do a perpendicular
bisector
we've seen that before sometimes you can
take the interval between two points and
then you like
extend it in opposite directions and
then you like take out the middle bit
right we've seen that before
here the interval between our two
reference points
what is its significance to the actual
locus that i'm after
the answer is we have a word for this
right that interval
what's its relation starts with the d
right but what's the relationship with
this
semicircle it's the it's the diameter
right the interval
is the diameter that's what we get when
we see
an equation like this okay
so semicircles now i want to um
push you guys to see if you can
understand what's going on here right
um take that same equation that we wrote
right the first one right up here okay
and what i'd like you to do is um
underneath where you've done all this
working and drawing your own diagrams
right
i'd like you to write the same equation
but
i'd like you to write the fraction in
the argument
write the reciprocal looks like this
now we've just gone to the effort of
trying to demonstrate
trying to prove that if you have
something in this form
you're going to get a semicircle okay
and this is the geometric reasoning
underneath y now i hope you're somewhat
convinced
that this will also be a semicircle
right it's got the same
angle in the semicircle being a right
angle you even have the same points
one and three but there's a difference
in the order
if i were to do that same trick that i
did before i need this uh
this one comes first and then
this one comes second
so i'd like you to play on desmos for a
second right you actually have
everything you need
in front of you and see if you can find
where is the shape that actually does
this to us and if you can find some
points
and trace them out uh then commences
laser eye over and see if you can
explain why
would you please draw for me a new
complex plane
it's going to look much like the one you
drew
at the beginning but with a slight
difference you're going to see why in a
second
now some of you have found an answer but
you don't know why it is what it is and
that's that's a fun thing to wrestle
with okay so before i
launch into trying to understand what's
going on here i should mention
emmanuel absolutely picked me up on this
and i didn't get to it yet
um i've got two end points here right at
one and at three
and my graph on the again diagram is not
perfectly correct on those what should i
replace these with
i should replace them with empty circles
thank you june because
and you can see it right above in this
line of working here right
at the point 1 or at the point 3
if you were to try and substitute into
this equation
you land on a problem don't you if you
put 3 in here you get r
of zero which we said is undefined
right and same deal if we try to put one
into here you get our zero
and it doesn't fly okay so we do not
include these two points
now let's come over here the same two
points are relevant so i'm going to mark
them in and i will put them with hollow
circles this time
here's one and here is three okay
now think about this with me right and
we kind of skipped over this bit of
logic before
when we said this right this angle will
take away this angle equals pi and 2.
that clearly kind of implies that one of
the angles is bigger than the other
which one like you already know from the
diagram but can you tell me
it's it's it's got to be z minus 3 that
angle right because
big take away little will give you a
positive thing right if you did the
other way around
if this angle was large and you
subtracted it then you'd be in trouble
this would be a negative
result make sense and that is why i kind
of took you instinctively
to this region on the r gams diagram
because
that will give you an obtuse angle here
acute angle here and your home
makes sense but no matter where you move
p around here right this is preserved
which is the
the thing we want yet that's not what we
want over here look again
at the difference between the equations
right can you see in this case
we want this argument to be big and we
want this one to be small does that make
sense
yeah big one small one it's never going
to work
here in fact it will never work anywhere
above it's so far i can't even like i
break my diagram right
anywhere above the axis you're in
trouble
so you actually
have to go down below and this is what
we need to put onto our diagram right
let's let's find a spot wrong color
let's find a spot down here uh say
like i'm going to put one about there
let's consider a point p like that a
value for z that would put p
here what are the relevant arguments
z minus three and z minus one now i'm
going to do a bit of a weird thing
i'm not going to use a principle
argument here i'm not going to use a
principle argument
because underneath here our principal
arguments would be
negative do you agree you come from this
side and you rotate around that way
okay we're doing subtraction subtraction
of negative is famously confusing so i'm
not going to do it
i'm going to choose instead these
reflex angles right they've gone past pi
radians
so this is arg of z minus three
is that okay with you yeah um i did it
with a little a so i don't need a
principal argument
and then this angle here
that is arg of z minus one you okay with
that
can you clearly see and you can put onto
your diagram too i'd love you to as well
just by the way i've drawn my angles
right clearly
this reflex angle is larger than this
reflex angle
does that make sense now in order to
then go about and i'm going to leave
this as an
exercise to the reader in much the same
way that we did some triangle geometry
here
to show that this would be pi on two i
want you to go ahead
and it's slightly different even though
it's quite similar try and show
that this angle in here will also be
pi on two so we will still get a
semi-circle
it's just on the other side okay
now the question of course is well how
can we know that right like
now we've demonstrated it but how can we
like what's the logic that gives you one
above
or one below it's actually not to do
with above
or below it has to do
with the direction in which we measure
angles
think about the eigen diagram right if i
gave you some random z
and i said okay well let's imagine the
interval to the origin where would you
start again
just measuring the argument positive
real axis and then which way do you
measure
you measure anti-clockwise
if i had a point down here right you'd
go all the way around you take the long
path right you only go the other way if
you're trying to do
negatives that's the principal argument
now because we always measure
anti-clockwise have a look at which
angle is big and which one is small
which one comes first and which one
comes second
in this case three comes first and then
one makes sense
so what we do is we measure anti
clockwise that's the direction that
we're going
from the first complex number to the
other
over here what's going on same deal it's
still
anti-clockwise it's just you've changed
where you started
and where you ended does this make sense
same points but when you do in reverse
order
anti-clockwise gives you the bottom
rather than the top
and you can imagine like i could put any
two points anywhere
right if i wanted that part of the
circle
which one would be the first number if i
call this one
let's call one w and one z
which one would be first should be w
and then you go clockwise around sorry
anti-clockwise
to z make sense if you wanted the other
semi-circle
this one you'd put zed first wouldn't
you and then you continue
anti-clockwise until you get to w
you okay with that